مرحبًا ، أنا سيلين كوري ،
لقد تم تشخيص إصابتي بالجنف
منذ عامين
، وقد حدث هذا أثناء المدرسة أثناء ممارسة الجنس
وكنت أركض وعدت إلى المنزل
مع ألم في الظهر
ثم فحصته أمي
ورأت أن ظهري لم يكن  مباشرة
لذلك ذهبنا إلى الأطباء
الذين قاموا بفحص ذلك وقال إنني مصاب
بالجنف وهو مختلف بالنسبة
لكل شخص ، يمكنك الحصول على انحناء أم البحر
أو مثل العمود الفقري الملتوي ولكن
لدي فقط منحنى على ما يرام ونحن نحاول
قم بتحسين ذلك من خلال الذهاب إلى نيويورك للقيام
بهذه
الدورة الصيفية المسماة skully smart بعد
المعسكر التدريبي الذي قمت به ، رأينا بعض
التغييرات ولكن بالطبع علينا
الحفاظ على هذا التغيير من خلال القيام بالتمارين
كل يوم ،
لذا فإن أسبوعًا عاديًا بالنسبة لي هو البدء  في
يوم الاثنين
بعد المدرسة ، أقوم
بتمارين البيلاتيس الفيزيائي ، وأقوم أيضًا بجهاز المشي ،
وقد صنعوه مثل البدلة بالنسبة لي
لأعجبني فقط بالذاكرة كيف أمشي
وأتأكد من أن وضعي في وضع مستقيم ، لذا أفعل
ذلك لمدة 30 دقيقة مرتين في
كل يوم كل يوم كل يوم سبت أفعل
شارع  إنجث وتكييف كل
صباح لم يمنعني حقًا من فعل
أي شيء ساعدني في الواقع في
عقلي أيضًا على أن يكون لدي
نمط حياة صحي صحي
لأكون صادقًا ، لم أكن
أعرف حقًا أن رياضة الجوجيتسو موجودة
حتى أخبرتني أمي بذلك
و  أعتقد أنه كان مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا في
البداية ، ووقعت في حب
المجتمع
[الموسيقى]
خلال بطولات أم الأخيرة ،
كنت متوترة حقًا
عندما شاركت فيها ، لكن بعد تلك
البطولات ، شاركت في
العديد من المسابقات بعد ذلك
، وقد قدمت أداءً أفضل مني  فعلت في
البطولات مما يدل على
أنني تدربت وفعلت ، لقد تحسنت أكثر من
ذلك ، لقد
تعلمت أنه يمكنك
المثابرة ويمكنك المحاولة بجدية أكبر
على الرغم من تشخيصي بالجنف ، إلا
أن ذلك لم يمنعني من القيام بشيء في
الواقع  ساعدني ذلك على
تحسين عقليتي وأعتقد
أن هذا أمر جيد حقًا
ويمكنني وأعتقد أنه يمكن أن يلهم
الآخرين لفعل المزيد
وتجربة أشياء جديدة أيضًا